interview vérité the prairie
tout à fait j'étais en 1943 c'est en ça
non citi dit il n'a pas l'habitude de la
télé c'est le mot ni fait juste suite et
michon vous êtes dans 43 votre mère
était aide-soignante à bitche en moselle
dans un hôpital réquisitionné par les
allemands et votre père avait été dans
la ligne maginot qui est servi à rien il
sait faire prisonniers se retrouvent
dans l'hôpital il rencontre votre mère
et vous naissez et j'arrive ensuite vous
allez je la fais courte a besoin en
pension et l'abbé relâche de 10 11 ans
vous subissez les abysses et l'abus
sexuel
je subis pas non je suis témoin d'abus
sexuels sur des enfants parce que nous
étions dans un pensionnat de 2,2
deux frères qui s'appelait saint-nicolas
dini et la mode à ce moment là c'était
de devoir cesser ses frères mettre les
petits garçons entre leurs genoux
c'était leur grand plaisir dans trois
ans d'enfer pierre boudier sérieusement
oui sérieusement et on attend d'en faire
et où il fallait faire à 11 ans toutes
les phrases que pourquoi atterrir mois
et de ses jambes a fallu courir vite
quoi entre autres après donc c'est
l'époque de l'algérie et l'avait
fricoter un peu avec ios vous mettez des
bombes
1 hoyé entre autres un peu lui dire
maintenant elle n'était pas là était pas
là n'ont pas encore bombe à l'hôtel de
ville
ben c'est pareil c'est une des des
affaires que je me sens je me souviens
parce qu'elle n'avait pas explosé
brest est due à notre inexpérience sur
nous c'est une bombe à retardement elle
s'appelle tiberi alors vous avez parlé à
françois mitterrand de votre époque un
peu os comme ça et elle rien truc que je
comprends pas c'est que lui il a fait le
parallèle avec ce qu'il a vécu pendant
l'occupation
je vois pas ce qu être comparables sa
part où j'ai peur de comprendre
simplement bon quand on est jeune qu'on
a lui il avait 18 ans quand il est
arrivé à vichy moi j'avais 17 ans quand
y avait cette guerre on était dans une
période tous les deux de deux conflits
de guerre et lui il avait besoin de
travailler l'été monter à paris il est
redescendu à vichy donc on lui a accordé
un poste dans un ministère moi j'étais
jeune chien fou j'avais envie de bouger
j'avais envie de m'ennuyer chez moi donc
je suis parti avec ses sept banques
quittez pas toujours très fréquentables
donc c'était une boule un petit
parallèle mais wec à rien de donner un
peu d erreurs de jeunesse lui sur les la
francisque et vous cette elwes et ça
voulait dire par exemple d'accord j'ai
contrôlé j'ai compris alors vous fait
tellement de conneries finalement
georges est obligée de choisir entre la
prison où vous la remet à l'armée
et vous avez choisi l'art mais voilà
alors je la fais courte en 62 ou
retrouver dans les pas renvoyé en
algérie en 69 vous rentrer un peu dans
la politique de la campagne de power
personnes ce qui pourrait aujourd'hui ça
j'imagine pas pour un boulevard aux
enfers
en 71 vous rencontrez française qui
alfortville d'habiter alfortville
l'époque où mitterrand montre le ps
c'est l'époque d'affiner un vous prenez
votre carte du parti socialiste laitiers
socialistes n'ont entendu tout non en 74
ou participer à la campagne de
mitterrand c'est quand il a perdu contre
giscard d'estaing faire des saints et
après la défaite
buvez un pot avec lui comme ça enfin
quelques jours après vous première fois
me conduisait dans votre ds staff à une
nuance très sale et puis madiba emmenez
moi à saint germain des prés voilà et là
où tout aurait pu aller bien pour vous
tout aurait pu être formidable et vous
recommencez les conneries double vie
mais est ce que je vais dire charlotte
je parlais du bim double vie d'un côté
eliane avec les enfants et de l'autre
côté annie avec julie voilà et c'était
bien ce que sympathie est très
sympathique mais enfin bon il ya eu un
problème j'ai eu un petit peu le même
que mitterrand d'ailleurs c'est que
votre enfant est mort d'un mort subite
hull où j'habite et mitterrand et avait
le même problème après la guerre dans
146 avec daniel exartier la rapprocher
un petit peu je sais pas c'est passé
concours de circonstances qui l'ont
quand même une personne je vais pour
s'acquitter tellement attaché mazarine
en même temps quand on sait ça moi je le
savais mais c'est ça quand on sait qu'il
a perdu une petite fille ont très très
bas âge peut-être que c'est pour ça
qu'il a reporté tellement d'amour sur
sur mazari voilà vous c'est dur pour
vous vous conduisez le cercueil a dit
dans la famille de de votre ami dix ans
et là vous tombez dans l'alcool la
dépression un peu clochard donc le char
et bien soir j'étais entre deux voitures
allongé dans le milieu de la route
franceschi pas s'est dit tiens il ya un
chien qui encore en train de mourir
entre deux voitures
dd va voir ce qui se passe des divisions
et va voir gardien et puis dit non c'est
pas c'est un chien c
pierre tourlier qui est en train de
sombrer alors il me ramasse mais dans sa
voiture il montre chez moi il dit demain
je dois au bureau en état il nous a
dreux - des trials a quand même fait
franche et ce qui est acté française qui
sera le maire d'alfortville un député
maire d'alfortville et alors là donc ils
vous demandent de protéger le premier
secrétaire du parti donc françois
mitterrand et vous dites dès cet instant
j'ai compris que mon destin était lié à
cet homme racontez votre première
journée quand vous les avez tous années
chez dos d'un bouffon puisque vous
regarde que lui ça la guilde des visages
alors de ces basses et le premier jour
le soir donc on le midi la vitesse d'un
restaurant puis le soir on arrive place
maubert à côté de la rue de bièvre et
puis bon ben j'ai de jeunes à indy puis
l'avant ce qui avait d'extraordinaire
c'est françois mitterrand c'est que
jamais il disait aux chauffeurs vous
restez en voiture vous m'attendais
françois mitterrand il avait cette
allure extraordinaire c'est qu'il dise
on chauffeur vous venez déjeuner soit
quelqu'un de lui faire manger en cuisine
il a dit et ce soit à côté de moi et
donc françois mitterrand était
extraordinaire pour ça et donc je
m'assieds à une table pas très loin de
lui et puis je vois qu ils m'observent
et roger hanin aussi qui m'observent et
moi j'avais mon couteau et me fourchette
savait plus comment servir tellement
c'était impressionnant quoi un levier le
trac
tout à fait vous dites la voiture
c'était une sa bulle son havre de paix
et alors ça sert à quoi il écoute est
vraiment que pink floyd dans la voiture
oui j'écoute ça c'est celui qui m'a le
plus étonné depuis dix ans mitterrand
gai écoute binck leur aide ils fouillent
supertramp les bee gees s'est il
chantait jamais cru ça c'est un truc que
mitterrand écoute les bee gees dans sa
caisse le ténor et donc là je parlais de
mazayes vous découvrez la double vie de
françois mitterrand donc un rapproche un
petit peu parce que lui je pense qu'ils
devaient savoir comment ça se passe pour
moi donc c'est ce qui nous rapproche un
petit poème ou trois semaines
il prend par le bras le bras en sortant
de la rue de bièvre il dit hier je crois
que nous allons travailler longtemps
ensemble
alors vous dites d'ailleurs qu'ils
avaient avec danielle mitterrand à un
couple qui était bâtie sur le respect
mutuel c'est ce que vous dites et puis
avec anne pingeot une véritable passion
amoureuse quoi passion amoureuse pour sa
fille il était subjuguée par elle est
alors totale autour de ça et une omerta
considérable enfin vous saviez vous vous
étiez au courant parce que du tout les
gens lewis était au courant apparemment
ils n'ont jamais dit
gens qui lisent les journaux mais je
crois que c'est l'honneur des français
de savoir faire ça c'est à dire que on
peut être au courant de certaines choses
base organique là on a beaucoup de bons
plans quinquennaux maîtresse à l'effort
c'est un truc nationale
chacun ses qualités en ce moment moi
j'ai dit je vis en espagne
et bien je peux te dire que la presse si
tu veux et d'un trash et d'un et c'est
vrai que moi je suis le voit choqué on
n'a pas souvent l'occasion du wpt d'être
fiers d'être français sur ce truc là je
trouve que l'on est assez classe ouais
bien alors vous dites que mazarine et la
femme de sa vie en fait et alors il ya
un très beau très beau moment quand il
vous dit dépêchez-vous pierre on va
chercher d'alsace qui appeler comme ça à
l'école et la banque vous vous découvrez
un mitterrand complètement transfiguré
en fait triste quand ça s'arrête on est
subjugué par sa fille quand elle arrive
quand je vais la chercher à l'école
j'apprends par la main en plus moi
c'était un petit peu dans le renouveau
de ma fille que je venais de perdre et
donc je l'amène à la voiture et on voit
ce françois mitterrand qui est heureux
2-2 à travers la vitre on voit qu'il est
heureux de recevoir sa fille de de
démarrer dès qu'on démarre il embrasse
il à kalin et on arrive devant chez elle
est là il ouvre la porte et vos mazarine
partir et là ils le disent une triste
note d'un père qui se sépare de sa
raison alors qu'il ya toutes les autres
femmes il vous disait j'aime être aimé
quel mal y at-il à ça et vous vous dites
hui volume suffirait pas riche mais ses
conquêtes quand même alors il ya
christine à la suédoise donc vous
confirmez
d'une certaine façon vous dit qui peut
pas être le père de l'enfant parce qu'à
l'époque la maladie l'interdisait la
paternité sur et là il ya elizabeth
teissier donc l'astrologue ok mais qui
voyait le sol si elle se fait d'essayer
brise est resté syndicale voyait
mitterrand mais qu'en fait ils croyaient
vachement à l'astrologie qui voulait
faire une chaîne une chaire parts dans
deux d'astrologie la sorbonne musique
que c'est du pipeau tout filmé santé
c'est la taper
j'emmerde je vais réfléchir il parlait
de l'astrologie pendant des mois en même
temps bon c'est une personne agréable à
regarder
voilà n est pas mal il avait été envoyé
des trucs qui sont rigolos injurié une
militante du psg de drague et puis nous
dragon passé la soirée avec elle mais
qu'elle ait un jour mitterrand non non
une militante du ps qui drague pierre
voilà puis je me laisse aller et puis
quelques jours plus il va chez elle il
s'aperçoit que c'est un endroit où il
avait déposé
mitterrand déjà quelques jours avant ces
français au moins ça me choque
non les scouts ouais non mais c'est
intéressant comme bouquins et alors il
ya une nuit mais il ya une île était
clinton dans un lit et il ya quelqu'un
qui téléphone qui vous vire le méchant
dire de son appartement était sans
vitesse m'habillant sur le palier et je
sort de l'immeuble je tourne la tête au
moment un taxi arrive et je reconnais là
s'il y perd en france que le terrain
rivenet mais là aussi je continue la
chandelle j'adore ils y arrivent avec
des pierres brillé à la fin se fait pas
c'est lé là dessus parce que quand il
vous dit ça y est pierre se termine je
suis désolé en fait de faire du chagrin
à ceux qui m'aiment et qui vont arriver
en lançant son grand con souci c'était
la mort c'est ce qui gênait le plus
c'était de faire du souss du du chagrin
ce qu'il l'aimé la dernière fois il
avait 2 vous l'avait conduit en voiture
ils étaient des mauvaises nouvelles de
son toubib et
vous lui dites five i'll docteur tard au
fait de lui une dernière fois vous allez
voir paris vous saviez pas que la
dernière fois bien ton nom
donc vous avez regretté à près de palu à
voir rester accroché au volant la résine
ont alors vous dit pour conclure j'avais
perdu le père que je n'avais pas eu
françois mitterrand était le dieu d'une
religion que je n'avais pas voilà bon
ben on rallume la lumière serge